this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks for the nice introduction
um
and for you know putting out loudly
titles so we can move on to it um before
I I dive into the the subject I'll just
make a very brief introduction of you
know why
how I ended up working and he has gases
wasn't my original idea right um or or
when I was in girls school but during
the postdoc I work in a project that was
called uh climate credit excuse me
climate friendly farming and you know it
was kind of a
type in into all aspects related to what
is today uh so relevant that was many
years ago we don't need to know how long
ago
all right so let's get to it
so I'll give you a two minute run on on
a on a conceptual framework just just to
land into the subject matter success is
a small molecule uh plays a very
important role but it doesn't come from
nowhere it comes from all the stuff that
we do to our land we conceive you know
the provision of ecosystem services in
an access there conceptual access and
agricultural output in the other axis
you know you can think of the natural
systems provides a set of relatively
limited agricultural output yeah they
are not meant to do that but uh you know
also production of ecosystem Services
um kind of a conceptual low input system
the Green Revolution essentially and in
our historic trajectory has been to our
systems that are a bit more intensive
and that produce a lot of
about that and have a very high
footprint on environment or you know
lower provision of ecosystem Services
you know they are high input low
biological diversity they produce a lot
of externalities
and our goal is to move into this
societal space
so this is essentially you know that
second Arrow going up is in the business
that we are now trying to move the
system in that direction
uh we really occupy most of the land in
terms of whatever is habitable we are we
are only the footprint is is you know
it's pretty pretty large this is some
sort of level of
um
you know how the landscape has been
trying uh changed by humans this that's
necessarily mean there is
it means that we are everywhere India
China Europe uh the eastern part of the
United States around the Lakes parts of
South America
um the parts of the green that are less
inhabited or affected the area of the
Saharan uh the tiger and that area you
know Greenland and parts of the part of
the rainforest
um but in general we affect a lot of the
land
do we produce an effort we there is a
lot of talk about food security well we
praise a lot and cheaply you know
um in quotation marks uh is of course
not well distributed
some things that I can see here
um here is a figure for the US of the
increasing the yield of corn for
instance and and I bring that this graph
that we all know very well if we work in
this business that corn productivity has
been going up so has been that of many
crops in some areas it might stagnated a
little bit but the reason I bring it up
is because when we communicate with
producers so that people that is related
to agricultural reproduction not
necessarily to Academia
um and we talk about the challenges of
climate change what they have in mind
maybe without thinking explicitly about
it is that productivity is going up so
there is a bit of a mismatch in the
message between okay we know we may be
facing uh dramatic challenges ahead and
what they are experiences with increased
productivity that doesn't mean that
there aren't uh big challenges but we
need to make an effort to bridge you
know a complex concept which is climate
change and how it affects many parts of
the globe at once but not every day or
every season in the same way and what
they people observe in the field but
back to this figure
um you know we can see just an example
of the our productivity we are very
familiar with this the midwestern USA is
a Powerhouse in terms of production at
the cost essentially of affecting all
the land these are just this is console
for instance uh the green yellow color
uh the similar case in Argentina you
know in the Pampas excuse me here
uh and it's changing recently Paraguay
as we will see and in the Arc of the
forestation you know in the Amazon basin
so message we produce a lot
uh of course the production is not well
distributed around the world you know to
the left we see uh uh in in red color
where is some sort of index of poverty
and and you can see right mostly in
Africa is also good to consider the size
of Africa compared with the with the
mass and with the population that it has
for continents and this is one in which
it is deformed to represent the
production of cereals in which there are
a few Giants the United States Europe if
it is considered as a whole uh China
India
and the likes and of course sub-Saharan
Africa is completely compressed you know
compared with some land demands so we
produce a lot we don't distribute it uh
or it is not distributed better set
um
evenly
I think yeah there is also uh a lot of
land use change which you know I was led
to see in the recent reported okay PCC
that this is getting a bit more
attention we all we all knew that it was
severe but we
I wasn't sure that everybody had a sense
of the magnitude of the challenge there
um here is a map for example of South
America and the little square represent
this area is called el Chaco which is a
region that most of you may never heard
of it but it was one of the last
deciduous forests uh in the subtropics
that we have you know this is in part of
Argentina this is part of Paraguay this
is part of Olivia and you know it's kind
of a continuation of the Serato of
Brazil that I'm sure you didn't care
about
and the yellow color here is the area
lost since the 2000s right it's such a
massive area this is about maybe two
times the size of or or roughly the size
of Pennsylvania maybe larger uh in just
20 years so sometimes when we try to
lower uh
agricultural intensity in some areas we
better make sure that the only thing
that we are doing is just pushing it
elsewhere which is really a tragedy in
both hands right or can be at present in
both hands
um
this is related from some of the
current challenges in the world for
example a crop failure in a poor country
that doesn't have the capacity to uh
replenish uh food supply with Imports
you know will cause social unrest after
social unrest we will get in some cases
of migration
of course migration will put the stress
on the receiving country right because
in general countries are not organized
to receive in the thousands or sometimes
millions of
of of refugees of some sort of migrants
that causes social unrest in the
receiving country and some countries
react you know trying to build a wall
um this is not uh this is not a very a
real joke of sorts it's just the reality
of what we are living through now and
and even though the standards of living
in the world on average
are increasing the number of displaced
people can be very large and
a problem in one place skill solder in
another place there is no such a thing
as a disconnected part
so sustainability is relevant in many
regards when we think about nitrogen
globally I will ask you to keep in mind
this figure this is from 2004 it's a
little old but I think it will convey
the message
we move a lot of nitrogen around the
world
some of it is through the production and
exports or import the fertilizer so this
you know just look at the thickness of
the arrows try not to memorize the
numbers not to point
um but there is a lot of nitrogen that
is produced industrially in an added
again for example in Europe as
fertilizer so it's the case in North
America some of it is imported some of
it is exported and then the grain
produced with most of that fertilizer
will be traded you can see that of
course not all the nitrogen that is
added
is it portable move around just a
fraction of it and some of it is
consumed some of it is used to feed
animals some of it is used for biofuels
and finally some of it is also traded
you know as meat and you can see from
the original a lot of production and
trade of fertilizer to the thinner
arrows of
nitrogen that is traded in me on
different types of needs um you know we
can get an idea of these the the arrows
will get smaller which means that
nitrogen is being lost along the way you
know in other compartments that are not
the ones that we are tracing around so
that's the type that's the nitrogen that
we are dealing with the one that is lost
um and this is what happened in our
region that you know well I can move
very quickly through it the bar on top
shows the the area of Forest Mississippi
Bay the area of hay crops past your
cropland and urban roughly you know in
proportion you know the size of the bar
is a proportion what do you occupy in
the bay
and this is the proportion
of nitrogen level that comes from each
language right and cropland you know
goes from a very small proportion in
terms of total area because Forest
dominates the bay
um but a very sizable component of the
of the nitrogen pollution so that 26
means 26 26 but on average 26 kilograms
of nitrogen per hectare as nitrate that
had lost to the Bay right
uh Urban centers of course also
contribute by the way for the nitrogen
low to the bag
and about 50 of that is coming from the
from foreign
which ones are the main
um
time-wise you know where the the not
emissions excuse me the loss has
happened there but with emissions it's
not that different uh so do we need
excess food supply yes because we need
uh in some regards yes to supplement the
variation that happens through years of
course to
to keep the prices at the level that
doesn't affect people without income to
access it but it cannot be a Mindless
access right externalities otherwise
um
will essentially flood us right at least
with what level of pollution we want to
live in the world that's some transition
that we need to make collect we need to
make collectively in the price that we
pay for our products
Armin I'm sorry to interrupt but your
sound is mostly good but it's cutting
out sometimes I don't know if there's
anything you can do being closer to a
microphone or anything that that might
help or not sorry for the interruption
no problem I can come closer I think one
of the issues is that there is a
construction outside and I I didn't go
to the office because there is
Construction in the office but the
construction here too and I think when
they start hammering it cuts off
automatically
um that's that's my only guess
maybe I was so cut off that you couldn't
hear it
we can hear we can hear almost
everything it's just cutting out
sometimes
all right well we'll just carry on thank
you I'll try to be slower too so maybe
you know less is lost I don't know if
that's a reasonable thing
um so how about nitrous outside
[Music]
um well you know very quickly nitrous
oxide in terms of total nitrogen losses
of all all those big arrows that is so
it's a very small component very small
um it's just very important as a
greenhouse gas you know it's a uh three
atoms molecule that has you know the
exact Optical properties to actually
trap uh radiation that otherwise will be
lost to the atmosphere for and
re-radiate part of it back and therefore
is a tremendous in-house gas
it is very difficult to measure the
emissions I mean you know from the soil
because the concentrations are low and
the instrumentation used so far tends to
be a little bit expensive and not easily
Deployable uh but it is manageable yeah
and of course agriculture dominates the
global nitrous oxide emissions right in
the US at least is in the order of 80 of
the nitrous oxide that is immediate it
comes from agriculture so that one Falls
in our lab so to speak you know we have
we have the responsibility I will say to
take care of this one
um very quickly it comes from a
relatively complex nitrogen cycle but
it's a manageable one you know we don't
need to memorize everything here but I
trust that many of you know it well I
just want to show very quickly
um that the black arrows here represent
what nitrogen comes into a soil plant
system it will come as fertilizer that
what the f means in here
that can be in a nitrate form or in
ammoniacal forms can be nitrogen
fixation through the vegetation so the
vegetation pole here is represented
twice and once you dump it into the
system so to speak you will bounce
around different uh pulls and finally
some of it can be lost
we want that most of the nitrogen that
we apply here fertilizer through
fixation to go through Harvest so we can
manage the flow later on right but many
times first we had much more than what
is needed for multiple reasons and some
of it will make it through some losses
and some of the losses will be nitrous
oxide loss one of the losses is from
nitrification just the process itself
will release a little fraction nitrous
oxide not measure but enough to be
noticeable
and and the others the one that is the
culprit of the big emissions is the
nitrification that we will explore
exploring more detail later
and in an ugly redox potential type of
graph you know it is represented here
when we add an ammonia called Source you
know it will be further oxidized
sometimes in the presence of oxygens to
nitrate and in the process itself it
will release nitrous oxide that's
nitrification
when denitrification kicks in you know
for a different reason
in that case nitrous oxide is an
intermediate in the path right it's not
a byproduct but an intermediate it needs
to go through here and if this process
is truncated here and the reduction
doesn't go all the way to nitrate to
excuse me to dinitrogen we can get
tremendous losses nitrous oxide so just
for a second without looking at the
whole uh nitty-gritty detail then look
at this as a well as a wheel that you
know we are pumping nitrogen through and
we are an ammoniacal Source you know it
will notify in general it will notify
release a little nitrous oxide some of
it will go to nitrate if that nitrate is
available and hanging around there it
can get denitrified who is more into a
um and then you know get to the
atmosphere nitrogen fixation may make
some of it back into an ammoniacal form
and they will continue so the more we
pump this wheel the more metal success
we get
so what are the ingredients for the
nitrification you know there is the
measures of nitrous oxide to go on well
we know it well but we can review them
very quickly the viability of nitrate
you know it's essentially the software
um low label organic carbon sources
residues you know greenish easy to
decompose so the microbes can respire so
there will be the electron donors
essentially and low oxygen when there is
oxygen nitrate won't be used as a set of
electrons and under four denitrification
will be new near zero right uh but as
soon as oxygen goes down it kicks in
in that little phrase as soon as oxygen
go down that's a very loaded phrase
essentially because the soil when the
Microsoft was fighting and the roots are
respiring consume oxygen and the source
of oxygen is the atmosphere therefore
there is a bit of a gradient
between the concentration of oxygen and
air and that in the in the soil
atmosphere and the regulation of the
oxygen concentration in the soil
atmosphere is the one that will enable
or not uh denitrification
it has to be low if the concentration of
oxygen is zero meaning completely anoxy
conditions the nitrification goes all
the way to the nitrogen and it's a
nitrogen loss from the system called it
a loss from the system but it's not a
source of nitrous oxide the problem is
that in between between a concentration
of oxygen that is not very high and one
that is not zero and that threshold so
we challenge you to Define exactly what
it is but you know we will go through it
in a sec
all right so let's go to the example
that I mentioned in the in the abstract
which is you know what happens in
systems in which we use organic sources
so snapshot the first quadrant here
shows
how nitrous oxide emissions usually look
like so here is a corn phase in a
rotation this line in here just
represents a timeline through a rotation
let's go through a cover crop through
corn cover crop again through soy to a
winter grain which is typical in some
areas here in the in the Northeast line
and this corner in particular is
receiving inputs of nitrogen essentially
format the cover crop that is uh killed
now when incorporated as we will see
and manure and right after this
applications of nitrogen you know we get
this peaks of nitrous oxide emission so
this pattern is very repeated in in our
system add nitrogen and the thing is
fresh in there we can pick emissions
then they essentially disappear
it's very simple the problem is that the
the type the exact timing of the team
the the length of the peak you know how
long is that emission um
wave you know some people call it the
hot moment uh it's and how tall it is
it's extremely difficult to predict
right
um in the system that we were working
for example in this case and I will walk
you through the one that is here you
know in this little square so you don't
get completely
um you know you don't zoom out with all
the colors and boxes you know this is
the rotation with that winter grain a
cover crop of sorts corn cereal Rye
soybean and when there is a manure
broadcasted here and then a mobile Cloud
we get the case in which the cover crop
and the manure are added uh in the soil
at once and we get the emissions right
after right in the two months after that
which is essentially
the way that we are seen here so we will
see you know how do we explain this this
emissions how they matter how can they
be managed
um
that's what happens on the feed level at
the landscape level sometimes we get a
landscape pattern of emissions of
Microsoft which is a lot more difficult
to detect because Landscapes can be very
large right how do you measure things
everywhere and assign The Source
essentially the emission but for example
if we think of a conceptual uh stream
that is done here and a watershed you
know that goes up to the Upland here and
we have a crop plant crop plant in the
upper part and maybe switchgrass on any
other
covering the lowland some sort of buffer
Street you know the fertilizer may go in
here
some of it will move uh with the water
and when it is in an area that is wet
enough to have low oxygen concentration
it might be the nitrified so
conceptually
um
that the pattern of emission may look
like this this would be a normalized
nitrification meaning the nitrification
is higher in this area next to the
stream but lower in the areas that are
better drained but the nitrous oxide
emission will be a little different
right the emissions will be higher where
the nitrification just starts right but
when the nitrification is
essentially going at full speed because
the oxygen is essentially is zero then
there is no denitrification so we get
some sort of
uh nitrous oxide emission front that
moves up and down the landscape during
rain and you know after the relaxation
event it starts moving down as long as
there is nitrogen that makes it
difficult to measure
so do we see this type of thing in the
landscape we do so here is for example a
small Watershed you can imagine that the
stream goes through here and drains on
this part so we have it off here there
is a forest
um and the Dots here show the intensity
of the emissions of nitrous oxide here
is pretty high if you walk in this
direction you're going down to the
stream and if you walk up in this
direction you walk the string so it's
kind of a v-shape uh watershed
Mission high high high low low you know
all low essentially all around high in
the lower
and the color there is this the the
amount of air
um in the soil
I hope you can hear me well now because
my internet connection says unstable
um yes it sounds okay Armin thanks
perfect
um 0 to 20 you see that there isn't much
of a relationship between the the
circumference of those dots and the
color right as we go down in the water
in the soil to the 20 40 centimeters all
of a sudden there is quite a
relationship there right between the
spots that are emitting a lot of nitrous
oxide and the
and the most and the air content in the
air and even a good correlation with the
air really deep 40 to 60 centimeters
um tips so this is essentially a hinting
on some of the processes that are uh
controlling the emissions you know mind
you many times we measure from 0 to 20.
uh start from 0 to 20 is not what
explains the emissions here
let's keep going
um in the trial that I mentioned that I
was showing you before with the cover
crops where we had manure I'll walk you
quickly through we went there we
measured nitrous oxide essentially twice
a week during the growing season
collected in the thousands of data
because there are too many plots
um
and then we you know we had ourselves
with all the state and we just started
doing analysis that says well this
linear related to that we can do a
multivariate analysis
and that's very difficult to discern
what is going on with nitrous oxide
because of the variability but there is
one at least one method you know random
Forest among many machine learning
methods that at least let you explore
what variables are related to the
emissions is essentially on on you on
the analysis to realize what are the
relationships but it tells you
here are the varios that seem to have
some bearing on the on those emissions
right
um so and these are I'm plotting two
different experiments one is the one
that I just showed you
uh and with this published and you can
you know review all the analysis there
and it is telling that the emissions you
know the further you are in this
direction you know the more important
the value of the emissions tend to be
related to how much manure is in the
soil because we added it the carbon
dioxide flux you know the soil
respiration rate essentially
uh the precipitation in the priority
days and the legend biomass these two
are very correlated because of the
timing of the emissions I mean the
biomass and manure rescue so if you
remove one from the analysis all the
variants turns to the other and vice
versa
um
and
and very little with the water filter
space right which is usually the one
that is using many models to actually
model nitrous oxide emission so this is
hinting that carbon dioxide has
something to do with the emissions a
different experiment in a different in a
different location although near near
this one uh with which finish
essentially analyzing you know two weeks
ago uh is showing
similar similar patterns we didn't have
the manual rest your leg in biomass here
so they are not in here it's not a fair
comparison statistics but once again
carbon dioxide emission and
precipitation in the period two days
uh come up as the most important value
of explaining the flux
so if we did oil analysis you know we
look at the expression of
of DNA we look at isotopometer analysis
which means you know looks at the actual
um distribution of the
of the isotope of nitrogen in the
molecule of n2o depending if it is
bonded to the nitrogen or to the oxygen
you know it represents even more the
nitrification or more nitrification in
short these emissions are from the
electrification the big ones and and we
need to explain how how that happens
right and here is how the story seems to
go
um oh yeah before that there are
interactions it is for example a plot of
manure residue versus legume rescue and
you can tell you know the edge here is
when there is no manure this is these
are the emissions that will happen this
only depends on the legume these are the
emissions that will happen if this only
depend on the on the manner but when we
put them together there is a synergistic
effect right or there seems to be a
synergistic effect
based on our analysis there are a lot of
interactions I really can't bore you
with this slot which is one of my
favorites
but when we develop what we call a
feature contribution
a lot for example legume residue against
the variation the emissions you can see
besides the color pay attention to the
color but you can see that there is kind
of a tight Association and a
threshold-like response but it is
telling that when it gets to this
essentially two megagrams of biomass or
1.8 then emissions are high and stay
high
but below that there are no emissions if
we look into this one we chose the
response of nitrous oxide emissions
to carbon dioxide to respiration flux we
see a kind of this channel positive
relation but very disabled this type of
analysis is still that high respiration
is associated with the with the
emissions that is interacting with other
factors that's why it kind of looks
scatter shot a little bit but upward
this one that doesn't have this
uh
that look and it's tighter it means that
it interacts very little is that
regardless of all the variables this one
will drive emissions High more or less
following that time
so we have a lot of hints that carbon
dioxide is related that ligands have a
threshold type response
um and things of that nature by the way
you see that the shapes are all this is
the type of thing that you can do with
this non-parametric methods we are not
tied up to a linear quadratic or any
other form it just takes the form that
the data takes right
um
so hints here and there what provides
the emissions
um how important are these emissions
they are they are high so I we didn't we
didn't talk about rates but on an annual
basis let's say there are corn crop grow
in the middle of Iowa uh that emits five
kilograms of nitrogen as nitrous oxide
is emitting a lot it also depends on the
yield you know you have to scale this
and depends on how much nitrogen you
said but is the crop is managed on
average to have a an average
productivity and is emitting five
kilograms of nitrogen per hectare per
year five pounds per acre roughly is the
same that's a lot that's a lot of
emissions we are getting ambition system
the order of 15.
eleven six three fourteen twelve seven
four corn so this emissions are high
whichever way you want to look at right
very high in some cases
per year right per crop but basically
you know that's the bulk of the emission
in the year
on the corner
so what's the story so why do I use the
Seesaw catapult well
when we talk about organic agriculture
the use of cover crops and the use of
pasture rotations which has been one of
my favorite systems we essentially have
in our mind
a gentle process of nitrogen accretion
and then decomposition during the during
the serial phase then we plant the
legume nitrogen comes back then slowly
decomposes it's synchronized with the
nitrogen demand is is a very nice seesaw
right at least in in our mindset
um
but here is what happens what it seems
to happen in reality here so here is the
representation of the soil with a color
crop growing you know a little bit of a
I think the drawing represents of it as
a modest roots in this case
um
when we are going to plant corn usually
the cover crop is killed maybe a month
ahead or so
skill mode which is this uh Green Layer
here represents that the the color
chrome As We Know
and
manually sat on top of it and then a
mobile plow in some cases apply
particularly in organic system what
you know people's trying to bury the
seeds
doesn't mean that the marble blow will
go on every year but this is the case in
this experiment under four all the Slate
of manure and power crop that was there
ends up here at the bottom of the
profile and the upside down Roots just
represent the inversion of course as you
can tell in the picture the inversion is
not perfect but it's better than than
what that picture lets you see because
we met we we look at it we put some
color and and we take soil samples and
when you take a soil sample very often
20 centimeters below you get a bit of a
salad of the cover crop it was just
buried which is kind of amazing so you
get in a in a system that this is
simplification that looks like this
right
planted corn and it looks like this
right so what happened in that case well
oxygen will come from the atmosphere
and it will be consumed intensively by
the microbes particularly during when
the heat wave hits those 20 centimeters
right during the daytime excuse me in
the middle of the afternoon right heat
is moist the roses are fresh we just
added green leaves you know with manure
so you get a lot of respiration
when we get respiration
we assume that we didn't measure in this
experiment s that we are measuring now
that the oxygen concentration goes down
at the diffusion of oxygen down just
cannot replenish cannot keep the soil at
21 oxygen right
and therefore it hits the boundary in
which the nitrification kicks in but
because the pores are open
oxygen doesn't go to zero therefore
nitrification is the denitrification is
truncated a lot of the emissions
it's kind of a nice story that we told
ourselves but we haven't been able to
knock it off meaning you know can we
prove that we're wrong and every
everything seems to go in that direction
so experiments that we are doing now are
essentially measuring the oxygen
concentration in the different soil
layers uh you know while we have this
system and we have changed the
distribution of the of the residues you
know Distributing through the surface
through the whole layer to see what
happens with oxygen and with nitrous
oxide it's a little Advanced we haven't
been able to Tamper down the emissions
with the methods that we are trying uh
but we have a good idea what to do next
so there is more evidence that this
process is operating
um
yeah well I have a summary there that
you know essentially here we have a
denitrification a truncated
magnification reactor going on in this
way
you know we when I was working with the
student came up with this idea of oxygen
consumption in this field actually it
was working with the students in a
project in in Italy uh we took
extensions to an area in the island of
Sardinia here is Sienna Mainland
Mainland here in Rome island Italy and
there is a small area with a drain Marsh
that is very Sandy as you can tell in
the in the bottom and it's flatland
right seriously a sand dune that is
flattened and and
is managed to to produce corn silage and
receives a lot of manure so you can see
the silage
um being there and when we started
making nitrous oxide emissions which
which was meant to train the students to
measure the staff
we find humongous Dimensions from the
business as usual
experiments right this is an emission of
27 kilograms of nitrogen
as nitrous oxide in three weeks
I I don't know if this is a record but
if it isn't it's very close to it in
three weeks you know I just said that
five kilograms in a year is a lot uh 27
in three weeks is really a lot it also
has this pattern of very high emissions
what caught my attention in this system
is that if you dump water it just never
ponds right water will flow through will
flow through because this is sandy soil
and it's very important it doesn't have
any silt basically so nothing clogs the
pores and how can the emissions be so
high well it's a similar case usually
the addition of the slurries or some
types and lay by carbon that level
carbon three years very fast respiration
creates a small gradient uh excuse me a
sizeable gradient in the oxygen
concentration most likely and until this
message the nitrification no they
suspected the electrification was that
prevalent there but it is
so we are on to something I will think
let me show these things so here is one
of these models that you know Cycles was
developing in our lab and you know if
you have inputs of things
you will get outputs of things and in
the outputs one of them uh Is nitrous
oxide and therefore we can test what
happens with this at the larger scale
I can advance that the model
I don't want to use the word fail but
did I say that doesn't represent
nitrous oxide emissions with the
intensity that we see in the field when
the nitrogen sources are is from organic
manures or or cover crops therefore it
hinters that we are not you know there
are some processes that we are not
representing well we are working on it I
really love it and have love when that
happens because it means that we have a
learn and when something is learned and
you think something many things go on
better right but we are working on it so
when we run this model for example in
all of io1
in essentially in every clu in every
field
in IO which is in the order of you know
800
8400 almost a million fields uh we get
patterns of emission that mitos oxide
this is not a simulation
um well in this case this simulation in
which the same system was was simulated
uh all across Iowa but we can represent
the actual management or something close
to the actual management including the
manure management with about maybe 25 or
29 percent of the area of ior receives
some form of manure by particular record
so we are we are in a condition to do
assessments of liposuction how to
suppress them at a very large scale
and we can optimize systems in silica
too so here is an example of of running
antimodal Cycles in the Giuseppe Bay is
being modeled in every now in every
County but the uh the example that I
want to put here is that you know before
we tended to use the model in a way well
we want to try this scenario and then we
run this scenario but now with the
advances of of
being power we don't need to make those
decisions essentially
we can ask the system to start
developing scenarios that will optimize
for something you know you know for one
variable or for many values and in this
case you know we are just generating
rotations uh just to see that for
example in this case you know in the
Northern parts more or less where you
are at Cornell uh or the ones that are
at Cornell you know it tends to
alternate current soybean for instance
and and as you go south you know it
makes room for winter wheat in the
rotation now this is a very simple
simulation the point is that we kind of
start doing this to learn not
necessarily to follow the advice of the
computer mindlessly but to learn faster
you know what can be done trade-offs are
an important one because as you can
imagine uh we are concerned about losing
nitrogen as nitrous oxide you know we
might think ourselves we would do we
favor bleaching which sounds like heresy
you know for us we don't want nitrogen
to lead uh but if you don't want bleach
it may be lost as nitrous oxide that's
more or less what we are doing with the
color crops right we use them to trap
the nitrogen but we mind you know what
we learn is that well now that we have
it we just put it together with labeled
carbon source and if we put them in the
soil we better manage that process right
in a way when you learn how to manage it
because in the in the wrong conditions
it will be an emitting time
and how those does the nitricification
forms okay we're a little behind on that
one but we are working on that so here
is a watershed and this has been
triangulated to represent different
processes right in which every single
spot would be simulated by the water
that moves uh that drains essentially or
that excuse me not drains
um the water that goes over land one
else will be received by the next cell
over and the water that moves in the
groundwater will be received at the next
level so you have a physically
distributed
model of water that lets you trace
essentially nitrate movement and if this
works you know we will be able to see a
very quick
um movie here there it is so what you
are seeing there is that you know we put
some pollutants can be nitrate or
anything
and the colors that you see here are the
concentration of the of nitrogen in the
groundwater as you can tell you know
this one's you know they are all
connected because of the pattern of
drainage and the colors that you see
here the changes in concentration in the
Stream right
you see it's two years of precipitation
going through here is this little bar
essentially showing the rain events and
you see how this starts getting cleaned
up because the pollutant essential is
getting emptied out completely and in
the next rain I think is finally
completely cleaned out so this models
let us learn about the patterns of water
and nitrogen movement in the system it
will depend on which crop is there you
know which ones are the sink of the
nitrogen that is being removed but it
let us Trace what are the areas where
you know doing an intervention to reduce
nitrogen losses being those leaching or
nitrous oxide will make more sense right
or at least let us think without
guessing too much you can just do this
experiment in the field but you can at
least learn using those models
all right so how important is nitrous
oxide well today is maybe what 10 of the
signal a little less than 10 percent of
the greenhouse gas signal but it will
become more important the better we
control fossil fuel emissions right and
that is change and as we stabilize
carbon in the air carbon dioxide in the
air and maybe it starts going down
nitrous oxide and methane will be kind
of more relevant so this thing is not
going away we really need to get we need
to get a handle of it uh soon because it
will be more important as time goes by
because it becomes a more important
greenhouse gas the more we control
carbon dioxide I think something that we
need to be aware of I do recommend that
paper that is there on the screen
because I think they made a very good
point
so there are a few challenges to manage
nitrogen one of the things that I I
presume uh
within managed by creating in the next
in the next presentation but one of them
is that
we need to match the nitrogen supply to
the nitrogen demand but the nitrogen
demand is not fixed it depends on the
weather every year here is the variation
in yield for example you know through
here in a given Watershed you know if we
budget for this demand of if we watch it
for the average we are going to be short
here on the Nexus in the others right
that's the problems we all know it
doesn't go away it does create a problem
for nitrous oxide
one issue that I didn't manage and
mention much but it's I think it will
become more and more important is the
use of manure uh when we had 100 pounds
of manure to the soil we had 100 pounds
of manure and we have a good scale it
works but when we add manure
we may add the mass that we want but not
necessarily know the composition it
varies a lot Common Sense tells that
uh producer will come to over apply uh
just to be on the safe part because if
the composition is valuable and it hits
the average half of the time will be
short but probably we are the Nexus
which means that the axis the actual
axis will be really high right that's a
big problem and one that we need to work
on and the other is cover crops so I
think we need to promote them and we
need to learn how to use them to prevent
them from being a source of mitos oxide
that are you know research is underway
there doesn't mean that cover crops are
bad that's that's you know I really
would hate for that to be the takeaway
what I mean is that like anything else
in agriculture needs to be managed
the grass here by the way in this case
is showing the variations in nitrous in
nitrogen leaching in a watershed the
dots are measurements the other are you
know modeling attempts you know as the
Watershed that I just showed you there
and the important thing is that the high
emissions essentially are showing when
there was enough nitrogen in the system
to have high nitrous oxide emission
right still and it varies a lot right in
that Motors
all right so in conclusion
animations yes we can we need to find
the leaks we need to plug them and and
they exist and the more we measure the
larger they seem to be that's an
important message there measuring things
um
there are means to to improve nitrous
nitrogen fertilizer used they have been
great progress I would say maybe it's
underrated
uh how good some producers are managing
nitrogen but there is definitely
worldwide a lot of room for improvement
not only in the US but worldwide you
know China in particular and other areas
where nitrogen might be using access we
do need to refine the management of uh
organic sources of nitrogen this is a
very important while you know there is
research going on but we need to really
tackle this one full-on and there are
trade-offs there are trade-offs that are
welcome the trade offers how do we
manage nitrogen to prevent leaching but
to prevent also nitrous oxide emissions
there can be a trade-off there but there
are trade-offs globally too right as we
produce
for example less grains and those this
the Lesser production of grain will
require less nitrogen we will lower our
uh nitrous oxide emission Footprints so
to speak
as long as that grain that we don't
produce here is not starving produced
elsewhere right in which case we might
be doing a really bad costume uh bargain
there
all right
um here in the figure uh the figure of
the students learning how to use
automatic Chambers you know with
Margarita
and Antonio to Italian scientists and it
was a great project you can tell the
sandy soil there here is the barn there
from and some of the manure pits and
I think I put the the figure there to
say that transparent markets need
information and in the case of nitrous
oxide in many cases we are
we have a lesser knowledge that I think
is ideal uh to enable uh very
transparent Market to follow so we need
to measure things and that will make us
uh definitely learn progress and and
make this work
the acknowledgments to the students that
and others that have contributed a lot I
will highlight a couple
which did a lot of the work in the
Watershed that I mentioned and in the
one of the cover crop experiment Allison
that is working now in the current
iteration of the curriculum experiments
and Rachel that single-handedly managed
to almost single-handedly managed to
simulate all of Iowa
that essentially made the research
feasible finally the funding sources
that were kind enough to trust us with
their with their funds to do some of the
research USDA and a safe and one doe
Grant and one EPA grant that I forgot to
add here
all right uh
Jennifer and and Peter that's uh that's
what I had to say and we'll be happy to
take questions if we have time
thank you so much Armin that was
fantastic
um uh we're going to take some questions
right now if you have other questions
please add them to the Q a Jen is going
to post a poll while we're doing this
part
um so Jeff Miller asks with greater
infiltration we do have more NO2 loss or
do you mean n2o so more loss under
no-till
um it can
so the answer it depends it really
depends on the system and sorry to
answer it depends but
you have to have the three ingredients
at once the low oxygen the nitrate and
the source of carbon so if it is not
till that maybe the soil might be moist
which probably let you to think that it
can have more nitrous oxide emissions in
some cases yes but it's a nitrogen is
added underneath the residues let's say
10 centimeters below the nitrate is
there ready to be denitrified but the
carbon source is not so the nitrous
oxide emission might not necessarily be
that high
uh after a few years of No Deal another
funny thing happens is that macropores
develop and they tend to keep the soil
pretty well ideated uh that doesn't mean
that the emissions are low but there's
you know there seems to be higher
mitosoxide emissions in some material
cases but not always
hope that answers there the question
um the next question happened about
halfway through your talk it's from
Jennifer and it's not really a question
it's you'd think CO2 would be correlated
with soil temperature so it is odd that
the relationship to emission is so
different
um
it is it is uh sometimes we don't have
enough evaporation in temperature to see
it so the range of temperature variation
in the soil is not that large but we
measure we are measuring the
decomposition but yes there is a very
tight relationship and yes high
temperatures will tend to favor the
nitrous oxide emission because of the
consumption of oxygen for sure that's
that's a good point actually so one of
the one of the management practices that
we found made lower the nitrous oxide
emission is adding the manure or the
cover crop in the when possible in the
fall
and bearing it of course that makes it
source of leaching but it slows down the
consumption of oxygen that thing
decomposes much slower under four day it
doesn't create the conditions for big
blips of nitrous oxide is a lot more
gentle
so Jennifer also asks are you optimizing
for yield to minimize nitrous oxide in
the simulations
we can we haven't you know we haven't
done it exactly for that but we can we
can optimize for anything like this but
we can I think
every time that you optimize for
reducing a loss you get a little you
know uh hammer down in the yields which
tells me that our Obsession sometimes to
measure to manage crops to close the
yield Gap is a little bit
um maybe we need to be
a waste below the the yield potential to
really tamper down emissions
Jeff Miller says what role can enhanced
efficiency and sources play for
biological and fixation products applied
to corn
okay
I don't know I think in general anything
that will reduce the availability of
nitrate the collocation of nitrate and
then easily decomposable carbon Source
will reduce emissions
and fixators
you know soybean for instance will it
tends to emit less nitrogen because we
don't add nitrogen that is free
available the plant gets it and then
we'll remove it right with the grain but
if we have an M fixation and then we
keep that trash residue with a lot of
miter in the system well you know that
one is a risk for sure
okay
um and then Jennifer Ed says adding on
to Jeff Miller's question under no-till
let's assume organic with legume cover
crop killed with a roller crimper and a
well-developed uh and well-developed
macropores to facilitate good gas
exchange through the profile with that
suppressed denitrification
um
well that's a great question
um that's a great question because in
that case the residue will be in the
surface right
um I think it will depend I was
surprised in Italy at the high emissions
in a soil that was essentially a
macropore itself right uh sometimes the
macropos will create the conditions for
low denitrification but High nitrous
oxide emission because it permits
essentially for that nitrous oxide first
for the oxygen to get in so there is no
anoxia but the other is for the nitrous
oxide to leave the system before getting
further reduce
um
so I say that it's already in the
surface probably emissions will be low
unless you get a frozen ground and then
you get a the nitrification reactor
right on the surface which happens when
there is no mail
um
but it's probably lower but it really
depends in the case and I think it will
be yeah I will be a little bit too
doubly cautious actually giving you a
yeah I'm sure this will happen I'm not
so sure what will happen in that case
okay so Ethan asks have you researched
impacts of different cover crop mixes
particularly grass Lagoon mixes on
nitrous oxide flux compared to single
species leguminous cover crops yeah that
that's a good question I'm glad to glad
to get it too yes we are doing that
right now and we have one year of data
in which we measure very carefully uh In
a combinatorial experiment you know what
happens when we have processed to detail
in this case uh clovers and a mixture of
both and and things more or less go as
planned the grasses tend to be tend to
have much lower emissions right
but a little nitrogen stress car
um but yes they do have a they there is
a difference you know by a factor of two
if it is a grass or if it is a legume
roughly very much related to the carbon
to nitrogen ratio of the of the inputs
yeah good question
so Brian says great information makes my
head spin
um
uh trade-offs abound historically the
goals were reducing soil erosion and
optimizing fertilizer use and protecting
water quality maybe the new metric we
need is a system approach that measures
the total carbon footprint of a given
farming system
yeah I think I I think I think you're I
think you're right and and I think um
maybe it's not for us so either either
academics to decide what the system
should be but I think the public should
have very transparent information to
make these calls but where do we put the
weight uh you know what what is for what
do we want to pay for uh lower emissions
lower reaching it probably will vary by
area it depends you know what is your
worst problem if your problem is
drinking water nitrous oxide shouldn't
be the main priority but in areas that
don't have that problem maybe mitosis
should be particularly we have manure
additions uh where the emissions can be
your task
um so yes it is definitely a complex
subject it can be a system carbon
footprint is one but there are
depends what is the most pressing issue
locally right the problem with nitrous
oxide is that when you emit it you made
a problem with everybody else so you
made a minuscule problem for everybody
else but if everybody makes a means good
problem for everybody else we end up
with the atmosphere that we are having
today very high emissions
okay our last question is from Jeff any
work being conducted to develop manure
application equipment that can apply
later in the season through injection
uh Heather Karsten and many others
Heather Karsten in in our department has
been working heavily on that
and
uh definitely the manual injection
decreased some losses volatilization for
sure but it does increase nitrous oxide
emission
um so here is that there is a trade-off
right there
thanks for introducing all of the
trade-offs today Armin it was a
fantastic presentation and I hope the
rest of your sabbatical goes well
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu